gender dysphoria diagnoses have spiked
in 49 out of 50 states between 2018 and
2022 the only state that did not see a
jump in boys thinking their girls and
girls thinking their boys was South
Dakota which actually saw a 23% decrease
in gender dysphoria diagnosis so what
gives is there something in the water in
47 out of the lower 48 plus Alaska and
Hawaii is there something special in the
water in South Dakota or is not actually
a medical reality but rather an ideology
and social
contagion there is no evidence of any
major differences in the water between
South Dakota and the rest of the country
but there is a difference in the laws
South Dakota has not gotten on board
with in fact last year the state
formally
restricted for children a number of
other states have issued similar bans
but but unfortunately leftist activists
on the courts and elsewhere have
prevented the bans from being enacted in
most of them this is great news for the
people of South Dakota gender dysphoria
[Music]
gender the story is bad news for the
alternately misguided and perverted
people
pedling but the story is also bad news
for the well-meaning lower Cas L
liberals who believe that politics is
exclusively and eternally Downstream of
culture in this case it isn't South
Dakota refused to pass laws to
encourage and actively passed laws to
discourage it and what do you know South
Dakota is seeing less of this dangerous
ideology that's because the law is a
teacher and conservatives all across the
country should learn the lesson I'm
Michael nolles this is the Michael nll
[Music]
show welcome back to the show Welcome to
my home you know I broadcast from here
every now and again it's kind of nice
when the rest of the team at the daily
wire wants to play hookie and they shut
down my studio it's snowy here in
Nashville but it's caucus day we're not
missing a show this is Iowa caucus day
the first votes in the 2024 presidential
race will be cast today very very
exciting I think we probably know what
the answer is going to be but anyway
very very exciting uh also the other
reason we couldn't take the show off
today we had to broadcast is because a
Zoomer girl has gone viral whining about
getting fired from her job and so that
that's the sort of of news that you got
to you cannot miss it okay it actually
does tell you something about the
culture that somehow no one is talking
about so we'll get to all of that first
though the final Iowa caucus
polls have Trump with the biggest lead
that he has had yet remember the
disantis campaign has staked the whole
campaign on Iowa at this point initially
they were running a Nationwide race when
things were looking quite good and Des
santis was the clear number two at least
maybe was able to challenge Trump uh the
polls just didn't move it's not that Dan
santis is is a bad candidate it's not
that he's a bad Governor he's a great
Governor I really admire the guy I think
he's great I think the campaign has made
some missteps but even if it were the
greatest campaign ever I just didn't
think it was in the cards as I observed
from the beginning and I hate to say I
told you so uh so because of that they
put all of their resources in Iowa and
it does not appear to have paid off this
latest poll uh has come out at Trump at
48% Haley at 20% so Trump's got a 28%
lead 28 point lead over his next nearest
rival Haley at 20 over D santis at 16 is
pretty shocking I'm somewhat skeptical
of that that haly is actually going to
outperform D santis in Iowa I guess it
could could happen uh V at 8% which is
considerably lower I still think pretty
good numbers for a guy that no one had
ever heard of a year ago I think he's
done a very good job in this campaign
and he's been able to not have himself
be totally marginalized like a Andrew
Yang type candidate or like a even a Ron
Paul type of candidate he's he's avoided
that he's he's a very sharp guy he's
very disciplined and he might outperform
even this poll ASA Hutchinson still in
it
1% I I didn't realize he was still in
the race but I guess he is and then
there's a guy named Binkley he showed up
on the poll I've never heard of Binkley
but Binkley is in it and who knows maybe
maybe he'll outperform and get a point
and a half who knows there could be a
surprise seems unlikely uh but we'll
find out the votes will be cast right
now now in the meantime speaking of
trump and VI the the knock on VI for a
lot of this campaign is that VI has been
nothing but a stalking horse for Trump v
he's been coordinating with the Trump
campaign I never believed that by the
way in part because I know the guy and I
know that he's pretty serious and
principled and I know that he's very
ambitious and I just didn't think he
would run a race to carry water for some
other guy and it turns out that Trump
doesn't think that either because Trump
just came out and turned on VI he posted
to his social media Network truth social
he said VI started his campaign as a
great supporter the best president
Generations Etc unfortunately now all he
does is disguise his support in the form
of deceitful campaign tricks very Sly
but a vote for V is a vote for the other
side don't get duped by this vote for
Trump don't waste your vote the vake is
not Maga the Biden indictments against
his political opponent will never be
allowed in this country they're already
beginning to fall magga three
exclamation
points V then responded to this in a way
that was probably wise he didn't go for
the jugular on Trump he he seemed
shocked
almost he opens up he says I don't think
Friendly Fire is helpful right now and
and then he says I've stood up against
the persecutions against Trump and I've
defended him at every step I showed up
at the Miami Courthouse in solidarity
following his First Federal indictment I
filed a Foya demand to the Biden doj I
submitted an amicus brief this week with
the US Supreme Court calling to overturn
Colorado's ruling to boot Trump off the
ballot I pledged to remove myself from
Mains in Colorado's primary ballots if
they remove Trump calling on to santis
and Haley to do the same you can hear it
in V's tweet he says what what gives man
I've been good to you what I've been
nice the whole time yes I'm running my
own presidential campaign but why are
you attacking me and it is deja vu all
over over again this is exactly what
happened to Senator Cruz in
2016 what happened in 2016 you'll recall
all the never trumpers and the libs and
the whiny people they spent all their
energy complaining about Trump and Trump
picked them off one by one very
easily the one candidate who did not
really go after Trump or who went after
him in a a fairly moderate way in part
probably because he agreed with a lot of
Trump's
newly articulated conservative positions
was Senator Cruz but when it got down to
the end and Cruz looked like he was
maybe a real threat to Trump trump went
for the jugular at Cruz he wasn't going
to give Cruz a pass just because Cruz
had been nice to him and the same thing
is happening here with the
vag there is no
evidence no evidence that Trump ever
goes easy on people who challenge him in
any way a lot of people thought it might
happen remember Mitt Romney thought he
was going to get Secretary of State
under Trump and there was that Infamous
photo they're having dinner and Romney
just looks so uncomfortable and
embarrassed and there's Trump eating his
steak like just a complete animal you
just loving every minute of it even
Christy at you know Christie ran against
Trump and then Trump brought Christie
into the administration but he he
discarded him relatively quickly uh I
think the same thing is happening to V
here V has run a campaign that is pretty
well aligned with Trump issues and he
has been very nice to Trump and he could
be a very strong Ally of trump but
Trump plays to win all the time if you
ever criticize the man if you ever
challenge him even in a fairly moderate
way 8% no in in Iowa versus 48% even
that he's going to hit you eventually
and I think that's what's Happening Here
V is playing it as as well as he
possibly could but this was always going
to to happen do Donald Trump has one
objective at all times and it is to win
the man will survive he is a blunt force
object and he's demonstrating that yet
again in Iowa now we'll see if the
voters respond to that one issue I think
we should all agree on especially on the
right because we've had so many great
wins in large part because of Donald
Trump but in large part because of all
of the great work of pro lifers for 50
years is to defend innocent life and
that's why you got to check out pre-born
right now go to pre-born
docomo last year because of you preborn
network of clinics saw over 58,000
babies saved I was just kind of like
Lord if this is you know if this is the
way you know let me know if this is not
the way Give Me A Sign you know before I
walk through these doors and I was as I
was getting ready to walk up the steps
and touch the door knob you know a
guardian angel and he just told me he
was like baby you don't have to go in
there and he was like I know someone
that can help you just to see the
development of a baby that small and I
say baby because I mean he had little
arms and legs and I mean you know it was
actually a human you know and to see
that and to have that physical and that
contact once you look at that I think it
just pulls on your
heart thank you to everyone who made
this possible let's celebrate these
precious babies each of them is truly
miraculous every day pre-born celebrates
200 miracles for just 28 bucks a month
you can sponsor an ultrasound and help
save a life when a mother sees her baby
on the ultrasound and hears his
heartbeat it can be a Divine connection
that doubles a baby's chance at life
let's join together and help mothers
choose life just dial pound 250 say
keyword baby that is pound 250 keyword
baby or go to pre-born
docomo wle I really really support this
organization they fund raise separately
for their their administrative costs so
every dollar you give is going straight
toward saving babies uh you should give
right now I would strong recommend it it
is as efficient a way to save a baby as
I can think of go call pound 250 keyword
baby or go to pre-born
docomo Meanwhile the Democrats seem
confident with Trump as the nominee
Nancy Pelosi just came out and she said
it is impossible not unlikely not crazy
to think about impossible for Trump to
be president again
this is a neck-and-neck race and no one
feels very comfortable on the Democratic
side of things that Donald Trump isn't
going to be the next
president well I don't think that nobody
feels I think many of us know that it's
is impossible uh for him to be the
president again with what he is
proposing well because when you're
talking about what he's talking about
now is more tax cuts for Corporate
America taking them down so low to the
detriment uh of our budget and meeting
the needs of people but people have to
know I have said over and over again
President Lincoln said public sentiment
is everything with it you can accomplish
almost anything without it practically
nothing but public sentiment has to be
informed people have to know you can see
the backtrack happening in real time I
can't tell if it's if it's an
intentional wink or if she said the
quiet part out loud and then she had to
backtrack but she contradicts herself
there doesn't
she opens up she says some of us in the
political Elite we know it's impossible
for Trump to be president again impos
how's it
impossible he already got elected
president once is
impossible well uh no it's impossible
because of public sentiment is
everything yeah yeah he's the most
popular guy in the
race not even the most popular guy in
the Republican field which he is by a
long shot according to every single poll
he's more popular than Biden according
to most
polls and way more popular than Bobby
Kennedy Jr and Cornell West and Jill
Stein and so what are you talking about
if public sentiment matters then you
should say it's impossible that Trump
won't be president again if he's the
nominee against Joe
Biden well no it's because all this
stuff he's talking about with corporate
tax cuts what are you what she's just
reverting to the old Democrat talking
points from 20 years ago is Donald Trump
even talking about corporate tax cuts
maybe tangentially I haven't even heard
that on the campaign Trail he's talking
about we're going to build a border wall
I'm going to get retribution against my
enemies we're going to end all these
stupid Wars overseas we're going to fire
40,000 bureaucrats what what do you mean
corporate tax cuts that's just a total
reversion to the generic Democrat
talking point against the generic
Republican we know what she means when
she says it's impossible for Trump to
win again those of us in the no we know
it's impossible what she's saying is
we're going to prosecute him and throw
him into jail and we're going to kick
him him off the ballot because he's too
popular because we can't beat him at the
ballot it's going to be impossible
because we will not allow the people to
vote for him again that's what she's
saying that's been my hesitation on the
Trump nomination this whole time I don't
endorse in the races as a general rule
you know I really like Donald Trump I
like other guys in this race too I'm
friends with some of the other guys in
this race that's that's why I've stayed
out of it one hesitation that I have had
is that
they might just not let him win
again they might just kick him off The
Ballot or indict him or I don't know
they might assassinate him that'll be
the last thing left to do and that's
what she's
saying if we want to give the woman
credit she's a very crafty politician
that's what she's saying here she goes
don't worry the guy's not going to be
president why is that oh oh because of
his his wild rhetoric no that's not what
you're talking about at all lady or she
just blurted it out don't worry worry we
got this thing in the bag don't worry
we're going to change the voting rules
again don't worry the courts are on our
side don't worry we're not going to let
the people have a say because we care so
much about public opinion that we're not
going to respect the public opinion in
the race okay now speaking of
vampires much more important news story
than who's going to be the next
president Christian
Stewart has come out to say that
Twilight is quote such a gay
movie I never saw Twilight I'm V
familiar with the plot the plot is that
a lady falls in love with a guy and but
he's a vampire and then she falls in
love with another guy and then she has a
kid by the guys and she only ever
engages in heterosexual
relations but it's such a gay
movie what's she saying I can only see
it now she says I don't think it
necessarily started off that way but I
think that the fact that I was there at
all it was percolating it's such a gay
movie I mean Taylor lner and Robert Pat
Patterson and me and it's so hidden and
not okay I mean a Mormon woman wrote
this book it's all about oppression
about wanting what's going to destroy
you that's very Gothic gay inclination
that I love whoa hold on is this woman a
right-wing Republican is this woman a
social conservative now she's saying the
reason that this movie is gay is because
it's about Desiring something that will
destroy
you that's right out of the middle
she's saying the quiet part out loud
though she's saying that that is the
essence of what it means to be gay or
for a work of art to be gay is that it
has to be self-destructive that's that
is a more aggressive and condemnatory
statement about gay rights or LGBT than
anything anyone has said on the right
she goes on though she goes it's not
that I wasn't scared about coming out
and say apparently she's bisexual which
just means and she's a liberal woman in
2024 she says it was just that there was
no other way to live every single woman
that I've ever met in my whole life who
ever kissed a girl in college is like
yeah I mean me too I'm constantly joking
with my girlfriend I'll be sitting there
and be like she's gay too everyone's gay
everyone's gay they all think everyone's
gay
okay I think she's right about
Twilight even
though as an exoteric message as the
actual plot of the story from what I
gather never saw the movie uh every
single romantic relationship is
heterosexual I agree that the story
itself is
gay it gets to actually something that
she talks about directly but it gets to
why sodomy is condemned traditionally in
you know all the theistic religions and
threat our entire civilization I I think
today people think it's because people
are just prejudiced or bigoted or we
just we think the the the gays or icky
or something like that but that's that's
actually not why the reason why
is because it is contrary to Nature
that's why that's what St Thomas aquinus
said that's what the Scholastics
believed that's what uh Christians and
Jews and Muslims have believed that's
that's what Dante believes you know
Dante I always reference Dante and I've
got a little statue of Dante right there
Dante in Hell In The Inferno puts the
sodomites in the seventh circle and it's
the circle of the violent and people
don't really know why that is and and
it's it's not just that he puts them in
the circle of the violent he he puts
them lower than the murderers and the
suicides he say Dante says that sodomy
gay stuff what we now call LGBT pride is
worse than murder and suicide which is a
little harsh you know I mean but what's
his reasoning his his reasoning is not
that that he hates gay guys or something
in fact the example he uses in the
circle of the sodomites is his beloved
teacher Brunetto latini and it's not
even just about physical sex stuff it's
also about art it's also about Brunetto
latini's poetry his writing it's it's
about an entire ethic a way of viewing
man's place in the world the reason
Dante says is because murder is violence
against your neighbor right you go you
kill some guy the reason suicide is
worse than that is because it's violence
against yourself which is even more
contrary to Nature than killing your
neighbor and the reason Dante puts even
his beloved teacher Brunetto Latino who
he says is a sodomite lower than that is
because that is more contrary to Nature
still and it's more contrary to Nature
because it totally divorces the sexual
act from the t- Los of the sex the end
of the sexual act it's totally sterile
this is why in Dante the the punishment
is these guys have to well they all walk
around like a bunch of naked dudes
walking around which is probably not a
punishment in the minds of a lot of
these guys but what where they're
walking is on this burning hot surface
like the the hottest desert surface you
can possibly imagine which is a symbol
of the sterility of the ACT it's it's
not a fruitful act and so if you were to
put Dante aside for a second and you
think of the way that Christians thought
about this through the height of our
civilization uh you would take it even
further you would say that the the the
ACT being uh so contrary to nature would
mean that maybe maybe the worst sexual
thing you could do is when it's not even
between two people is when it's even you
know that thing that people do
individually when they look at their
computers and look at porn this this
this is why the pornography epidemic is
ultimately so terrible it's so contrary
to Nature and so getting back to
Twilight I think the reason why Kristen
Stewart is making this point I mean
she's making a point every bit as
condemnatory of of an identity that she
holds for herself as St Thomas aquinus
or or Dante would is is for that very
reason I mean it's a it's a vampire
story what is a vampire story a vampire
story is older people feeding on the
young that is totally contrary to Nature
the way it's supposed to work is that
the young feed on the old you know a
little baby feeds from his mother the
elderly nourish and cultivate and expend
their effort to bring up the Young
Generation and then that goes on
throughout the generations with what a
vampire story does is totally flip that
that is what vampire stories are about
and that's why they're so perverse it's
an actual inversion of reality totally
totally contrary to Nature and it has
all sorts of
uh bad political effects too because if
you know people are not fruitful and
multiplying then the political Community
dies you know then people just aren't
replacing
themselves this uh you know I I don't I
don't want to I don't want to even go as
far as Christen Stewart is going here in
her condemnation of the LGBT community
because the the real way of taking this
sexual ethic which today seems so crazy
but was the sexual ethic that informed
our civilization for 2,000 years
actually even longer than that the way
to take it to its logical conclusion is
to point out that the the real extreme
of it
is the GU is just looking at porn you
know completely divorcing uh the the
ends of sex from sex itself a form of
violence not just against your neighbor
not just against yourself but but
against nature and against Art and
against God let all who have ears to
hear Let Them hear it's going to be it's
going to be me and Christian Stewart
and Dante making this point and modern
culture probably will not want to hear
it one thing you probably do want to
hear though is how to fix your finances
which is why you got to check out
American financing right now go to
americanfinancing.net
it's 2024 a lot of us are trying to get
our finances in order there is some
great news for homeowners interest rates
have dropped down to the fives a lot
lower than where they were last year if
you have been buried in highin credit
card debt now is the time to Break Free
with American financing American
financing can help you access the cash
in your home to pay off your highin debt
last year their salary based mortgage
consultants helped customers save an
average of $854 a month that is like
giving yourself a
$10,000 raise what a way to start the
new year and if you start today you may
be able to delay two mortgage payments
call American financing today at 866 569
4711 that is 866 569
4711 or visit American financing .n net
nmls 182 334 nmls consumer access.org
APR for rates in five start at 6.2 75%
for well-qualified borrowers call 800
685 56 96 for details about credit costs
and terms speaking of liberal women Jill
Biden has come out to attack all those
nasty mean terrible
Republicans she says what what we at
large are doing to poor Hunter you know
holding him accountable for his many
many crimes which are personal and drug
related and sex related sure but more
importantly involve corruption involve
selling American influence involve
taking millions and millions of dollars
from corrupt oligarchs around the world
with implicit maybe explicit Promises of
of American state support as a result of
this just total corruption she says it's
cruel how have you been coping
personally uh with the onslaught of
accusations against your husband and
your your family including and
especially Hunter it's the focus of a
house oversight Committee hearing
holding him in contempt obsessing over
him showing pictures of him during
vulnerable moments in his battle with
addiction on the floor of the house this
would crush any family Ma I I think what
they are doing to Hunter is cruel and
I'm really proud of um how Hunter has
rebuilt his life uh after addiction you
know I'm I love my son and it's had it's
hurt my grandchildren and that's what
I'm so concerned about that it's
affecting their lives as well that's it
that's it I'm just so concerned you know
sure I I would be concerned if I were a
Biden because it wasn't just Hunter it
was Hunter's Uncle Joe's brother it was
Hunter's other Uncle Joe's other brother
it
was the whole rest of the family Hunter
was the bagman hunter made payments to
other members of the
family so did Joe's brothers and these
guys made payments to Joe and we have
the receipts and Hunter wrote in his
laptop and in text messages yeah I'm
giving 10% to the big guy at one point
He suggests that he had to give 50% of
the money he made to the big guy the big
guy being Joe Biden as Joe Biden's
brother pointed
out what is Jill doing
here she's playing her part in the pr
strategy there obviously is a very
formal crisis Communications campaign
underway to rehabilitate Hunter to make
him less of an issue for Joe in 2024
that's why Hunter showed up to the
capital he wouldn't go testify before
Congress in the closed door session as
he was called to do by the Congress of
the United States he gave a press
conference on the steps of the capital
and talked about you know how he's he's
just a a poor guy who had a run of bad
luck and he deserves sympathy from
everyone and everyone's being so mean
and cruel to him and then what did he do
he finally shows up but he makes a big a
big show of himself in a public hearing
he won't go to the private hearing to to
answer basic questions about his
business and then Joe comes out and she
does the same thing it's it's a very
well-laid out very particular PR
strategy I just don't think it works in
this age that we're living in where
where everyone films everything Hunter
Biden didn't just commit the crimes with
some receipts where we kind of heard
about it where we have good evidence
that he did it he filmed himself doing
it all the personal kind of just dodgy
crimes of passion and
incontinence he filmed all we all saw
way more of that than any anybody wanted
to
see and he sent all the texts and we got
the emails and we got we can actually
see it all happening in real time I
don't think it's going to work now
Hunter Biden had he had he not taken a
ton of money from crook oligarchs
overseas had he not been conducting
business with the Chinese Communist
party uh maybe they'd let it go but you
can't Overlook that so speaking of doing
business with
Communists the Holy Father has raised
some eyebrows because Pope Francis has
welcomed a group of marxists and talked
about how wonderful it is to have
dialogue between Christians and
marxists
it is not in my job description to
criticize the Holy Father I I might
raise some questions though here's what
the pope said I'm pleased to welcome you
the representatives of Diop who for many
years have been committed to promoting
the common good through dialogue between
socialists marxists and Christians a
fine program I would like to commend you
commend to you three attitudes that I
consider helpful to your efforts first
have the courage to break them old to be
open in dialogue to new ways instead of
rigid approaches that divide let us
cultivate with Open Hearts discussion
and listening and not exclude anyone at
the political social or religious level
second concern for the less fortunate
sure that's great finally the rule of
law dear friends I thank you for your
commitment to dialogue okay I'm a little
confused here
because many many popes for nearly a
hundred years now coming up on it have
in no uncertain terms condemned
communism and socialism and said that
Christianity can have nothing to do with
socialism and Marxism blessed Pope pasus
I 9th and qu purus in 1846 all the way
back said communism as it is called as a
Doctrine most opposed to the very
natural law speaking of natural law for
if this Doctrine were accepted the
complete destruction of everyone's laws
government property and even to Human
Society itself would follow well you
might say that's just one Pope right no
no it's not just one Pope Pope Leo the
13th in 1901 says har a harvest of
misery is before our eyes and the
Dreadful projects of the most disastrous
National upheavals are threatening us
from The Growing Power of the
socialistic movement okay put Benedict
the 15th 1914 it is not our intention
here to repeat the arguments which
clearly expose the errors of socialism
and of similar doctrines our predecessor
Leo the 13th most wisely did so in truly
memorable encyclicals and you venerable
Brethren will take the greatest care
that the those grave precepts are never
to be forgotten not even in 2024 when
people forget a lot of things poas the
11th no one can at the same time be a
good Catholic and a true socialist he
goes on he lambasts socialism papayas
the 11th too few have been able to grasp
the nature of Communism the majority
instead succumb to its deception
skillfully concealed by the most
extravagant promises Pope pasus I 12
says the same thing Pope John the 23rd
who's who is a liberal Pope at least
that's how he's considered says no
Catholic could subscribe even to
moderate socialism Pope Paul V
considered a liberal Pope said much the
same thing Pope John Paul second
constantly invade against socialism and
communism I mean the man is considered
an anti-communist hero of the 20th
century pope benedic the 16th who was
the most recent Pope uh before Francis
said uh the state which would provide
everything absorb everything into itself
would ultimately become a mere
bureaucracy and capable of guaranteeing
the very thing which the suffering
person every person needs namely loving
personal concern says we don't need this
we don't need any of that
okay what is going on
here Pope francis's comments are very
confusing I've made no bones about the
fact that I'm a mackerel snapping papist
myself I find it very confusing and I
find it confusing
because the church's teaching on
communism and socialism is not at all
confusing not at all I I just quoted a
handful of the I could we i' fill up
many shows talking about what the
Catholic church has said about
condemning Marxism and socialism so
what's really going on
here in charity and to give Pope Francis
the benefit of the doubt I suspect that
he's drawn in to this kind of a dialogue
in the way that a lot of good people are
drawn in to to want to have a dialogue
with Marxism and communism because you
you actually do have a care for the
common good and you care for the poor as
Pope Francis said and you care for those
who' have been left out and you want
rule of law and you don't want the
predations of a totally untethered um
liberal liberalized regime where of of
Les Fair capitalism where no one cares
at all about anyone else and everyone's
just avaricious and trying to to um
pursue his own personal interests to the
exclusion of a common good I I I get
that and they think that Marxism does
that but it doesn't and the the left
misunderstands that the the good ones on
the left misunderstand that the bad ones
on the left are fine with it they just
you know they they're deceptive and
duplicitous the thing is a lot of people
on the right misunder understand this
too I was talking to a friend of mine
years ago who suggested he was very
deeply read in marks and he
said if KL Mars were alive today he
would not be on the left or or he would
be on the left but he wouldn't be a
Democrat he if Karl marks were alive
today he would be in the tea party Carl
Marx is a radical
libertarian and I've had other Anarchist
friends and libertarian friends who have
made that point very few people have
actually read marks everyone about marks
for a few people have actually read
marks I from what I have read of marks
which is probably more than most people
though I nowhere near the man's total
Corpus uh I agree with
them I think what Marx was after was
total
Liberation that's that's the Utopia at
the end of Marxism is is a world of
total freedom freedom not not in the
traditional sense of order and
responsibility in toward the natural
order and natural hierarchies and ends
natural ends and doing what you ought to
do no no no the modern kind of Freedom
where you just do whatever the hell you
want all the time that's what Marx was
after the the Utopia at the end of the
of the Marxist program is where you get
to do just whatever the hell you want
all the time
and that that is the libertarian view of
Freedom it's a hard saying the
Libertarians would say no we're the
we're the opposite of the marxists
they're the collectivists we're the
individualists Carl Marx would probably
call himself a radical
individualist because they're two sides
of the same
coin Because the
actual opposition to Communism to
Marxism to collectivism is not radical
individualism it's the family its
structure its order its hierarchy its
tradition it's inertia it's the weight
of History radical collectivism and
radical individualism are both
revolutionary programs that that poor
acid on all of the institutions of
society that are both equally opposed to
the family and to tradition and to
everything that has come before
us that's that's the
issue and so
ironically what I think all those past
popes were warning about was that in in
Catholic Social teaching there's plenty
of concern about lesi your capitalism
going too far about individualism going
too far which is why you need
protections of the common good which
which is different than collectivism you
know the collectivism that the left
talks about is this kind of bizarre
modern clinical
utilitarianism where we determine the
common good by figuring
out I don't know the the most pleasure
for the greatest number of people where
we ignore individual rights where we say
well you know if 50% plus one benefit
from something then screw the minority
that's not truly the common good the the
true common good is everyone's
individual good as well and it
presupposes that we can know our own
good that our own good is not just
whatever you wake up Desiring that
morning but that that the good of man
can be known objectively through the use
of reason we were talking earlier about
the natural law that's what that's about
things have a purpose the leftist tears
tumbler has a purpose it gives me my
delicious leftist tears the microphone
on my Lael has a purpose it transmits my
malous voice to your ears man has a
purpose some of our organs have purposes
the eye has the purpose which is to
perceive the the uh visual world and and
allow us to interact with it in a
reliable way we hope other other organs
have purposes man has a purpose an
ultimate end too we can know it and we
can all flourish this is what
[Music]
the you
know the signature razor from jerem
razors the Precision five you need it
get one handle plus one blade cartridge
kit for only $499 it is crafted with a
luxurious tungsten handle five welded
steel blades and a Precision trimmer for
a close smooth shave around hairlines
and hard to reach places but remember
Precision 5 is no ordinary razor no no
it is a sword in the battle for beliefs
a banner to wave into a new economy a
Precision instrument to force w
companies to earn back your dollar and
stop denigrating your values but it is
also still a razor and will give you a
great shave the Precision 5 starts at$
1499 and with the price so low it has
never been easier to stop giving your
money to woke corporations that hate you
join over 200,000 customers who have
ditched their woke razors and switched
to Jeremy there's never been a better
time go to Jeremy
rers.us who said says my favorite part
was that Michael knows that the proper
word is normality and not normaly thank
you I'm glad you saw that people use
this word
normaly and it's a fake word it's a
madeup word all words in a way are made
up but but some are more made up than
others some are just mistakes that
people made that become common and
others you know derive out of an organic
process of of etymological change and
normaly is is in the former category
Warren Harding who I kind of defend a
little bit but he was not the The
Brightest Bulb that we ever had in the
white house he used that the return to
normaly was his motto for for his
presidential campaign and it's fake the
word is normality and as we increasingly
talk about norms and standards we we
should get that word right too that's
that's a norm that we should also
respect now I have a
question about the most important issue
of our
day and it's it's about this Zoomer or
maybe Millennial girl
whining about getting fired and I'll
hold my question until I assume you've
seen it it went totally viral but I'll
hold my question until
after she makes her display hi Britney
hi thanks for meeting with me and Rosie
um so she's writing on here she's an
accounting sa at Cloud flare we finished
our evaluations of3
performance she writes her name here
want to stand up for myself what do I
have to lose we' decided to par ways
with you yeah I'm going to stop you
right
there um so I started August 25th I've
been on a 3mon
ramp and then it was three weeks of
enjoy the trauma she writes and then a
week of Christmas her trauma I guess is
what she's talking we are she's writing
these things on the Tik Tok that she had
the highest activity amongst my team um
since I've started I have had three
contracts out done a really great job
managing my deals up until the very end
that decided not to close last minute um
so I don't think that that makes a lot
of sense for me in my cloud flare
Journey here so
far wow it goes on and on and
on everyone's talking about how she's an
entitled young woman she doesn't get it
you kidding me you buttercup you little
snowflake get with the program that's
one take then the the other take is yeah
Corporate America there's something
really screwy about it and she's
probably right and it's crazy how
clinical her firing was and that is
wrong and she yeah our economy is kind
of messed up and fair enough my take is
not either of those my question
is why does everyone film everything now
why it's kind of ironic I guess guess
cuz I'm filming a thing right now I'm
saying my thoughts on a camera to you
but one that's my job and two you know
it's
a I'm not filming you know every
traumatic event in my life I don't think
I'm filming any traumatic events in my
life I don't want to I don't want to
expose that I'm not even filming when I
go make pasta I'm not some of you have
asked me to do that but I don't really
do that I'm not the only time I really
film in my house if we're not snowed in
is when I'm making little ukulele videos
why is everyone filming your first
instinct you see someone getting beaten
up on the street you say I got to film
this you you you get fired from your job
you know you're about to get fired you
know it's going to be a traumatic
experience you actually write in the
comment enjoy the trauma and you say
yeah you know what I got to do I got to
stream my firing my humiliation what has
gone wrong with people that they do
that it's it's a it's a total
obliteration of private life to what
she's actually doing here it's a huge
mistake she might be in the right maybe
the company just made a mistake or
they're just laying her off they don't
really care they shouldn't have hired
her in the first place she was doing a
fine job maybe that's the case she's
making or maybe she's a huge problem
which would seem to be the case because
of look what she's doing here can you
This Woman's never going to get a job
again she probably have a better life
because of that I actually don't think
that working in the widget Factory is
the the most wonderful and joyful way of
life and I think that feminists duped a
lot of women into thinking it is and now
we have an economy where women feel that
they have to work and in some cases they
would face real Financial problems if
they didn't work and those are all
legitimate problems she's certainly
never going to get a job again though
once people Google her name that she put
out there but why why would you why
would you obliterate your private life
like that well you know actually just
occurs to me it gets back to what we
were talking about earlier with Twilight
and Kristen Stewart saying all those uh
homophobic things even though she's I
guess kind of a lesbian
and
it it it's a total
upending
of the natural
order part of the reason that Dante puts
his teacher Brunetto latini in the
circle of the sodomites it's not I don't
know what the guy did in his private
life it's not even really necessarily
about that it's because Brunetto latini
was a very famous poet who sought
immortality in Fame and and
who whose poetry Dante seems to accuse
uh was disconnected from True ends it
was totally in self-indulgent and
sterile and not fruitful and we do that
today we do that you know why this lady
is filming herself because we don't have
kids anymore I think that's probably why
not just because she's working and that
you know when when women are working it
makes them less likely to have kids but
because we want to be
immortal and the the the devil tricks us
into thinking that the best way to
become immortal is to become a big
celebrity or to I don't know write a
really great book and that's how your
name is going to live forever that
that's not actually how we become the
the natural way to have immortality is
to pass on your
genes it it's to pass on your genes
literally biologically or at the very
least spiritually to be a spiritual
father and a mentor and in fact that can
be more important but it's not it's not
to get Your Name In
Lights I get it's kind of ironic I got a
big light here and I'm filming myself
and I you know I I have a public career
but it's not the most important thing
that I do not even close to it it's not
that all has to be in service of
something else and it it was in our
society for a while and even when people
you know people would do all sorts of
sins for all of history it's a fallen
world but we at least had the right
sense of that we had the right sense
that the the natural way to have
immortality is to have a family and the
supernatural way given to us by
Supernatural Grace to have immortality
is to follow God and follow the only
begotten Son of God who is Incarnate and
who is crucified and is resurrected on
the third day and redeems us of our sins
and if we have faith in him we might not
perish but have everlasting life that
was that's how you actually get
immortality on the natural and
Supernatural level but we get distracted
all along the way oh I know how I'll get
it I'll write a pretty poem I know how
I'll get it I'll become an Instagram
influencer I was talking to sweet little
Alisa she was telling me because she she
Scrolls a little bit more on that stuff
than I do my my scrolling is Twitter her
scrolling is more like insta and that
kind of stuff she said there are people
who they'll post really humiliating
videos of
themselves you know looking ugly and you
know like eating gross things and in
this case you know experiencing the
trauma of being fired and but they'll
say wow I'm so pleased that I'm an
influencer wow that's something El
you're right you you get that 15 minutes
of fame but it's 15 minutes even if
you're the most famous guy in the world
it's 15 minutes you know and then it's
gone there there is a more enduring way
to have everlasting life
now I want to get to so much more you
know I'm a
tease Governor Dan santis I think
probably seeing that his campaign is not
doing as well as people had hoped he's
turning on the conservative media
we'll get to that Rand Paul has just
made a kind of endorsement in the
presidential race we'll get to that Mike
Lee has just made an endorsement in the
presidential
race but I'm not going to tell you
anything about any of that today that's
going to have to be for tomorrow we will
not have a member block because
Professor Jacob who's been sitting
patiently right there he's not even
sitting on I have a nice little couch in
my office he's not he's sitting on the
floor that's that's too hierarchical
actually the man should the man should
be sitting on a like a chair or
something uh but he did not bring me my
iPad so maybe he should sit on the floor
okay in any case we might be back here
tomorrow maybe we'll be back in the
studio we'll see what happens in the
2024 race until then I'm Michael NS this
is the Michael NS show see you
[Music]
tomorrow